This going to be an intellectual chop
chop of Nuria step by step. I believe
Liam is her victim. I feel sorry for
him. Like I was watching thinking, you
know, like the guy's literally
traumatized over all these lies like
>> an ideology that I just I'm not going to
accept it period. Especially when you
are telling me this. I'm not talking to
to to Jim down the pub who's had a cut
the bevies and he's he's repeating what
he's heard from someone else in another
pub. I'm talking to an ex female Muslim.
>> Liam here, he's like, "Listen, I'm not
talking to some idiot who's drunk in the
pub who's heard something about the
Sharia law." It's like I'm I'm talking
to an ex-Muslim. You know this. Can you
imagine? They're so obsessed. They
identify as ex-Muslim. Imagine I had
women walking around saying I am who are
you? I am. They don't even say the name.
I am the ex-wife of Ali Dawa. Ex-wife of
Ali Dawa. I'm an ex-wife Ali Dawa. Oh,
I'm an ex-wife Ali Dawa. I'm like bloody
man. So these these these ex-wifeives of
mine are quite bloody happy. They're
identifying you know not even their
name. If I was aware that there was a
man in my community beating on his wife
or girlfriend because she was joining in
with him singing and I got wind of it, I
would draw him. Go draw Tommy Robinson,
bro. Yeah, he is known. He was caught by
an undercover officer while he was
abusing his wife. Go draw Amin who threw
a flipping chopping board at his wife.
Go draw Paul Golden who was locking up
Jada.
Ladies and gentlemen from all around the
world, today is Sunday, July the 27th,
2025 and we gathered here in South Gaza
Strip most to share our concerns about
the ongoing crisis in Gaza Strip. During
the humanitarian crisis that Gaza and
his people are undergoing,
food in general and flour, bread
especially, it's becoming luxurious and
rare. It's not available for the
citizens. So our mission here to support
the citizens and to help their their
lives to be better by giving them these
trips. On behalf of those citizens and
those families, we thank forever for his
wonderful support. It will be a reason
and making the people happy. Thank you
for being a reason in this effort.
Ever
[Music]
halam
brothers and sisters and dear friends,
I've got an epic video for you guys and
I'm sure Liam And uh this Nordia girl is
going to be watching this. It's going to
be an absolute pleasure cuz they talk
about chop chop square in Saudi Arabia
where chop chops happen, but this going
to be an intellectual chop chop of
Nordia step by step. I believe Liam is
her victim cuz Liam was actually
shocked. Like oh my gosh, does this
Sharia really say this? Oh my god. Like
I feel sorry for him. Like I was
watching thinking, you know, like the
guy's literally traumatized over all
these lies. Like like there's so many
lies. And we're going to bring
evidences, by the way. It's not it's not
it's not me changing the word and the
Arabic. No, no, no, no, no. We're going
to go straight to uh the source. Yes. Uh
we're going to go straight to the source
in SH Robin Sisters. So Liam, for that
matter, I just give a little um context.
Liam invited me to the podcast and he
changed and swiftly changed his mind
when I told him that I'm going to
intellectually chop chop Tommy Robinson
into pieces. So he realized, you know
what, I don't think it's a good idea
because I think Ali knows what he's
talking about. I'm not the smartest at
all, but you know, he knows what he's
talking about. So, it's not going to be
a good look where I'm good look when I'm
going to dismantle uh Tommy Robinson uh
the the one who works closely with
Mossad who was obviously funding the
Epic Epson island of the pedophile
islands of course you know the white
middle-aged men like Tommy Robinson who
were taking advantage of um pubescent
girls but yes he didn't want that so
Liam T and he's also proved to us that
he's not an Islamophobe he's he's a nice
spoken gentleman by the way he was quite
polite yes he's proved to us that he's
not a Islamophobe because when you go on
to his Tik Tok Liam tough on his
Instagram you scroll down and you see
one Muslim there. There's one Muslim
there. There's so many Islamophobes
there, ex-Muslims and all this kind of,
but there's there's one Muslim. It's
like a it's like a KKK, a Klax clan
member who's like, I'm not a racist. Uh
why? Because I have I interviewed a
black guy, you know. It's very
interesting. You know, he's got all
Islamops, but he's got one Muslim imam
there. He's like, "See guys, I'm not an
Islamop. For some odd reason, he does
not want to talk to me. I don't know
why." I even invited him. I said, "Look,
off camera, let's go for a meal. Ask me
all your questions to if you're
genuinely looking for the truth." But
again, he seems like a lovely man who
speaks. He's like a nice spoken
gentleman and I'm sure his brainwash and
we're going to see in this video, we're
going to dissect it bit by bit chop chop
square style to see what this woman had
to say. Let's get straight into it.
Sorry for that blubbering. Just want to
give some context. Here we go.
>> And then as I'm sure you've heard the
like Islam and the Quran tells you that
you know Jews and Christians and
especially polytheists, but Jews and
Christians are on the wrong path as
well. Um, so you'd feel like you would
feel this superiority complex that you
know you're on to something and you're
living life on the right track and
walking by a pub that's somewhere you'd
never step into.
>> Okay, just quickly, have you read the
Old Testament? Have you read
Christianity for that matter? They say
the same about Gentiles. They say about
others that worship other gods and they
would not go to a pub, you know, as as a
Christian. I mean, if you think about
it, you know, they shouldn't be if
they're really followers of Christianity
or Jews. The same thing applies. What's
your point? Judaism, Christianity,
Hinduism, whatever it is for that
matter, they have belief systems. It's
the same thing. So, what's it got to do
with Islam? You're making it seem like
Islam is the only one that I can't go to
a pub. Uh, yeah, same with Christianity
and Judaism. Let's carry on. I hope you
guys enjoyed the video, guys. But before
that, please download the Salah Pro app,
brothers and sisters. We are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free Kiblinder, no ads, free salah
reminders, encourages to pray, tells you
salah times. You can book a salah
instructor, a Quran instructor. You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. videos on how to pray salah,
salah hubs, and many, many more wrong
sisters. We are not an app that shares
your information with third parties. All
of our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy,
guys. Let's go back to the video.
>> You said that in Islam for a girl stroke
woman. 9 years old is a defining age.
>> What does that even mean?
>> It means that things start to get
serious for you. Um, so gone are the
days now where you can, you know, wear
sleeveless tops maybe if you were doing
that or you're not allowed to wear
shorts anymore, even in front of your
male relatives. You should start to wear
hijab if you're taking this religion
seriously. And um, you're meant to be
trying to fast every Ramadan. You're
meant to be starting to pray five times
a day. Um, but basically now your body
becomes shameful and yeah, you should
start thinking differently about who you
are and why you exist.
>> Okay, interesting. Uh I mean I've got an
8-year-old daughter. I've got a
4-year-old and I've got a 2-year-old.
From what you're talking about chatting
absolute nonsense. Uh there is a opinion
of a minute men and black from 9 years
old, etc. No, even my daughter wearing
the hijab, it's something that was
slowly slowly telling her about it, etc.
But it's very interesting because if
you're talking about Islam teaches that,
you know, sexual objectification,
exploitation of children or whatever it
is for that matter. Well, as far as I
know, pedophiles, which are majority
white middle-aged men like Tommy
Robinson, um, and who are the main
corporates in this, if you got go look
at the 10 most prolific pedophiles, you
would see that not a Muslim, is there?
This is your problem. Yes, my friend,
this is a white man's problem. With all
due respect, I'm not trying to be
racist. Yeah. So, you can see, I mean,
let's just put this into perspective.
So, in Islam, it tells you that from a
young age, etc., when you start to
develop, your body's developing, etc.,
that you should cover up. But if
sexually if Islam wants to sexually
exploit you, I mean if you go and ask a
pedophile a question and ask them for
example, you know, would you like to see
a girl covered or naked? You'll say
naked. You know, and someone who's
perverted would want to see a girl
covered or naked naked. Islam says cover
up because Islam deals with the reality.
It doesn't live in this La La Land of
Disney World. Let's carry on though.
>> Firm was Aisha nine when the prophet
Muhammad consumated their marriage.
>> Yes. Okay, that would make sense as to
why when you're nine in Islam, it's now
time to start covering your modesty
uh and just completely sort of changing
and almost submitting to the religion
mindlessly.
>> You got it. Exactly. And honestly, Liam,
you're 100% right. This has just become
an issue in the last like decade or so
when um Islam scriptures kind of became
more readily available that they had to
scramble to make it a little bit more uh
like palatable or kind of defend it in
front of western audiences. But prior to
that nobody had an issue with the fact
that in Islam Muhammad married Aisha at
six and raped her at 9. Um there was no
issue. It was it was accepted in the
Islamic world for you know literally
years.
>> That's actually rubbish because if you
look at it's not just Islamic world it's
entire history of mankind. So now if we
see pedophilia as a mental disorder it
is a mental disorder. It's a sickening
perverted mental disorder that like I
said before the main culprits when we
look at different countries around the
world around the west are white
middle-aged men and women who are
committing these acts. So it's not a
Muslim problem, it's your problem, my
friend. It's the problem of the Western
world. But if we look at it as a mental
illness, are we trying to say that
majority of the population of the world
before the 1900s were all mentally sick?
That's what I'm trying to understand. Or
was this the norm? Now what you mean by
that? We you were talking about a child.
We believe that she was an adult. Now
it's very interesting because if the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him had
these inclinations, he would have all of
his wives that were 9 12. No, it's only
one wife. his first wife he was married
to which was older than him some say 15
years or 25 years older than him and he
was married to her for a long time so if
he had this inclination why did he not
do that when he was young secondly why
did he wait we've got many videos on
this I've talked about this over and
over again okay I'm an orthodox Muslim
she they they made a marriage contract
at the age of six and he contemated the
marriage at 9 because we are not
perverted like you guys to think in a
perverted way it's like a thief when
someone's a thief he thinks everyone's a
thief like him so because you have
perverted ideas you think everybody's
like you they're Not. So if that's the
case, why did the prophet Mhammed peace
be upon him wait 3 years 1,000 days
nearly, okay, over 1,000 days for her to
become an adult? Because if he has
attraction to minors, he would want her
body to look like a minor, which is
6year-old, 7, 8y old. Why did he wait 3
years? Because that is when Aisha Anhel
hit puberty. And we believe in Islam,
it's very clear, you cannot harm people.
A person has to be sexually, physically,
and mentally ready for intimacy. In the
UK, it's 16 years old. We have a
pandemic of teenage pregnancies. In uh
France, it's 15 years old. In America,
two quarter of a million girls are
married under the age. In some states,
it's 12, 13, and 14. My friend, this is
your problem, not our problem. So, this
nonsense is debunked. Let's carry on for
the next one.
>> When that happened, if you look into the
life of Muhammad, you can clearly see he
he eyed her up when she was literally a
little baby. And he he only, you know,
acted on that at six. He actually wed
her. to this is absolute bull crap.
Number one, this is an absolute lie.
Please show us any authentic narration
hadith that he was eyeing her up when
she was a baby. Nor, you're going to get
caught out. Just think you're going to
do a video and you know you're caught
out. You are exposed. Chop chop
intellectually chop chopped. Okay. So,
you can clearly see. Can you please
bring evidence? Not only that, Aisha and
her was proposed to before the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him. Which means
what? That was the customs of those
traditions until the 1900s. Why didn't
the Christian kingdom and the Jewish
kingdom or whatever for that matter have
any issue or ever use this against the
prophet Muhammad? Because that was the
norms of that time. You have the fallacy
of presentism thinking you at that time
looking back then things were totally
different. But let's carry on. things
that sort of drive me mad is one when
you put that argument to a a Muslim or
an imam, a leader, you know, a
spokesperson for the religion and
they'll say he'll say, "Well, well,
things were different back then." See,
to me, as a well- balanced man, I think,
well, it wasn't different back then. A
six-year-old would always be a
six-year-old, and a 50-year-old will
always be a 50-y old or 52, 54,
whatever. Sorry, with all due respect,
on what subjective grounds, Liam tough,
are you telling me that you are a well
um level-headed man or on what basis,
man? What your your your morality is
based on subjectivity? Yes. Okay. For
example, homosexuality. What do you
think about homosexuals? I want to tell
your opinion. What do you think about
drag queens? What about dee about those
who think they are a piano or a cat or a
mouse or you know, are you okay with
that? Oh, you say no, you're against.
Oh, okay. So, it's subjective. Okay. Uh
what about for example incest? Why based
on your worldview, you're an atheist.
Why based on your worldview is incest
wrong? or necrilia having in having sex
with dead bodies. Tell me on your world
view on what moral moral grounds it's
subjective morality and if not even that
even in some western countries they're
trying to make pedophilia. Yes. Or you
know having intimate with animals a
normal thing they see as a mental
illness or we need to accept them in our
society. This is your world my friend.
Liam this is your world not our world.
Our world is consistent. You will love
the shar. Liam let me tell you something
my friend. I know you're watching this
and you're probably smiling. Yeah. Liam
you are dying for the Sharia. You are
thirsty for the Sharia. And let me see
my let me tell you something my friend
on the 13th of September your freedom of
speech uh event last time I went I got
attacked for some reason they didn't
want my freedom of speech there. Yeah.
Um I'll be having a Dow table in Lester
Square. I would love for you or your
friends or buddies to come and have an
intellectual discussion. Yeah. Nothing
physical intellectual discussion. Let's
talk about this all day every day. I
challenge any of you guys to come and
see me if you have the guts. Yes. If you
have the guts, come and see me and we
can have a nice discussion. I'm talking
intellectually by the way. Yeah.
>> Consequences of this. For example, what
happens in Afghanistan when the Taliban
have come into power, men are selling
their little girls as young as, you
know, nine and below just, you know, to
be able to secure their next meal. And
why do they think that that's okay? Is
because under Islamic law, it is okay.
Like Muhammad's example was bad enough.
>> Sorry, one second. Can you please, this
is a second lie. Uh, Nura, hi there. Uh,
hello there, madam. Um, can you please
show us evidence where in Islam law that
it says that you can sell your
daughters, please? Allah says in the
Quran, "Do not kill your children out of
fear of poverty." So how could it tell
you? Allah saying that he's the
provider. Meaning kill your children is
is far worse than selling. So subhan
Allah, it is not allowed. You are not
allowed to sell your daughter's
children. What are you on about? A woman
has consent in Islam. Yes, consent. When
woman in the British in Britain was sold
when a man had a debt, he would sell his
wife. Man, what are you talking about,
man? Get the hell out of here. Bring
your evidence. Yes. That's where's the
evidence, please.
>> So, why why do Muslim women have to wear
a full face covering or or even just
sort of even with the face uh on on
display, but the rest of it all covered?
>> Oh, guys, it's about to get real
interesting with Nordia. Oh, she's going
to come out with so much facts. Um,
Saudi Arabia is different as well, but
essentially it all comes down to a verse
in the Quran and uh a story in Islamic
history which had I known and I'm sure
had any Muslim woman known before they
did it, they'd probably be repulsed at
why it's even come about in the first
place.
>> I mean, she's absolutely right. You
know, had had the Muslim woman known
this, they would have been repulsed.
There would have been uproar, etc. The
only problem is it doesn't exist. it it
there is not a single narration of this
dumb this bro it's just she just made up
a story that doesn't even exist bro hear
it for yourself
>> but um funnily enough it didn't even
according I I just go by what the
Islamic sources say it didn't even come
down initially from Muhammad himself it
was one of his companions his right-hand
man who was quite a thug actually um
Omar Ibab he would do these like sex
raids at night into neighboring like
villages and stuff. And so he
essentially would mistake some of the
women that he would like capture to
sexually uh harass as the Muslim women
because they would go to the fields at
night to, you know, um let nature take
its call basically.
>> Sex raids.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Raid a house, take a woman out for sex
against their will.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> Poor Liam, man. Look at this guy is
absolutely destroyed, man. He's like
watching a horror movie. What? What do
you mean? And he's like, "Yeah, you
know, that's what I do, Liam, on the on
the weekends after Friday prayer. I got
my Muslim brother, listen guys, we're
going for a sex raid." Woo! Come on,
guys. That's what Islam teaches us. Uh,
okay. One second. Actually, I'm not
allowed to touch the hand of a female.
I'm not have to date before marriage.
Um, if I get caught in Islamic law, if I
was to do anything like that, there'll
be a capital punishment. Uh, we're going
to come to that in a minute. But this
this is hilarious, man. Look at the poor
poor Liam. The guy's absolutely like
he's he's like, "What the hell are you
talking? Are you kidding me?" Poor Liam.
this man Omar Ib Kadab he is like a
degenerate in Islamic history and he
Muhammad was it seems from Islamic
history that even at times Muhammad was
afraid of him and kind of never wanted
to you know rile him up so I've done a
video about this as well there's a few
verses in the Quran which again made me
really question how divine is this book
and it's not at all is because three of
those verses that came down into the
made it into the Quran were um Omar Ibn
Khadab's wants essentially and he kept
begg like he kept like asking Muhammad
over and over again like you know Hey,
hey, let's get this in there. Come on
now. Um, so one night, Muhammad's wives,
um, when they went to answer nature's
call, one of his wives, SA, she's a
very, very tall lady. And so she was in
the, um, fields and Omari Makdab, was
wanting to go on one of his sex raids at
night, and he noticed her, and he
thought, okay, we need to stop um, if I
harassed her. She's obviously the
prophet's wife. So we need to put
something in place that makes me
realize, you know, as a marker who's
open for harassment and who's not. And
that's why I always bring it back to how
dark the concept of the hijab, basic
hijab or like if you want to go into
nikab and all that, it's even worse. But
even just the hijab is actually in the
Quran it says they don't even hide it.
It says um tell your Muslim women to you
know bring down their outer garments o
over their bosom so that they are not
molested or harassed. So what does that
mean? that all the women who are
uncovered are are free to be molested
and harassed. And it goes even further
because there's stories in the Islamic
sources where Omar ibn Khadab actually
um he punishes a woman, a slave woman
who was non-Muslim for trying to cover
herself to look like a Muslim woman so
she wouldn't be harassed. And he
literally uncovers her and says, "You
have to walk around half naked because
you're not a Muslim."
>> Wow. So, okay. So, let's dissect this.
We're going to go to actually primary
source material. Okay, here we go. So,
Katab for example he is he's at one
moment he wants to cover women up. Yes.
Cuz it's sexual objectification. And
then another one he wants to make them
naked. So so contradicted. Does he want
a woman to cover up or does he want them
to be naked? Okay. What are you talking
about? Now let's go to primary source
material. She's basically saying that um
he was the argument is but there some
woman that he was wondering. Okay no
problem. Let's go to primary source
material. Here we go. In let's dissect
this step by step. Okay. So okay. So
here we go. It is reported from more
than one for more than one that a free
woman and a slave woman used to go out
at night to relieve themselves in open
fields and among the date palms without
distinction between free woman and a
slave girl. There were corrupt men in
Medina who would harass the slave woman
and sometimes harass the free woman too.
If they were rebuked, they would say,
"We thought they were slave girls." So
the woman, so the free women were
commanded to differentiate themselves
from slave girls by dragged by dress and
covering so that they may be respected
and feared thus be not subjugated to
desire. In a nutshell is that both of
these women have been harassed and we
don't know who the men are. This can be
non-Muslim men. It can be because in
Medina there was Jewish Christians, they
were Muslims, they were they were
mushiks, they were pagan Arabs that were
harassing and slave girls. When we talk
about harassing, you need to understand
the context. Basically they were being
flirted with you know they were trying
to move to them you know in English term
this they're trying to move to them and
trying so what Omar Katar was doing
which there is not a single evidence
that Omar Katar was going to sex raids
please bring me please an evidence of
his story please a madeup story nowhere
it says that he was going so he said
that there are some slave girls who they
don't mind being flirted with child why
because if they got impregnated by these
men they could get their freedom okay
this was not in Islam this was in the
this was when Islamism established. So
these are men there was cuz there was
there was slavery then back then etc. So
there were these men who were most
likely non-Muslim pagan Arabs etc who
were doing sexually harassing name call
cat calling etc. And some of these slave
girls were about that life. So it's
saying to differentiate the Muslim woman
from that woman. So they don't think oh
they they want to be you know chatted up
etc. That's what it is. Not uh not only
that we've got another one. Let's go to
in give me one second. So the narration
is the following which is talking about
the prophet the wife of the prophet
Muhammed Omar used to say to Allah's
messenger let your wives be covered but
the prophet wasallam didn't do so so he
refused so was he was he now if that's
the case if your claim is that um the
second khalif was on a sixth raid okay
um the prophet would have said oh no no
cover my wife so you don't do it no but
he said he refused the prophet refused
please man allow it man please you think
you were not going to get caught out you
got caught out where is it why The
prophet allow them if he knows is doing
this stuff and he's oh my gosh I don't
want my wife to be a victim of this sex
rays that we're doing as Muslims. Oh
yes, why did he not allow that to
happen? You fool. You come on man. Come
on. Now the wife of the prophet used to
go to the call of nature uh at night
only at al-manasi once sa the daughter
of Zama went out and she was a tall
woman. So Omar Kab went out and she was
a tall woman. So while he was saw her
while he was in the gathering and said I
have recognized you OA he um said so but
as he was anxious for some divine orders
regard regarding the veil should we come
down so very clearly you can see nowhere
does it talk about sex raids or this
that etc and our literature shows the
evidence for we have clear evidence the
prophet's marriage to Aisha the 6 and 9
yes alhamdulillah we have context to it
we have no shame in this we would have
told that what sex is you talking about
you're a liar Yeah, you're an absolute
full-blown liar. Let's carry on. And not
only that, oh prophet, tell your wives
and the daughters and the woman of the
believers to draw their veils. And what
is the explanation of this? Allah
exalted says to the prophet Mahai
wasallam, oh prophet, tell your wives,
your daughters and the woman to cover
theelves, etc., etc., etc. to draw over
the hijabs so that no wicked man may
harm them with their words once he knows
that they are free women. So what is it
saying? is saying that wicked men this
can be a Muslim there are Muslims who do
atrocious things so the claim here is
what wickedness and the argument that
Islam says for example there's nowhere
Islam says that oh cover yourself men
can't control theirel this is talking
about an instance where there are
perverted individuals however in the
Quran Allah says what tell the believing
men to lower their gaze Islam teaches
from a micro level to a macro level to
teach our sons not to sexually objectify
any woman meaning I am not allowed to
sexually objectify non Muslim woman or
Muslim woman. I don't give you wearab or
bikini. I should not look at her. So
your claims are absolute bull crap and
lies. But let's carry on. Dissect the
nura. Like I said, this is this Alida's
chop chop square. Intellectual chop chop
square.
>> In your professional opinion, is the
burka a suppressive garment or is it a
sign of sophistication?
>> Absolutely. The former. There's no
there's no question about it for sure. I
think it's like a symbol of how
repressed women are. Um, if there was
even like a strong possibility that this
was like some empowered individual
choice, I would lean to say, you know,
it maybe it is that for some women. But
by and large, most Muslim women who wear
that, there are severe consequences that
they're about to face if they even try
to remove it by the men in their lives.
Honestly, the the coercion, the
psychological coercion that goes on
behind closed doors, just the
expectation that you're supposed to wear
it. And then even like within families,
the fact that you're told that, you
know, you have to cover up in front of
your uncles and people like that, it
perpetuates this rape culture because
the modesty culture is so embedded from
when you're a child.
>> Yeah. What the flipping hell are you
talking about? You are not allowed to
cover in front of your uncle. Your
uncle's your m you you Noria, please,
please, I feel sorry for you. Can you
tell me where it says you have to cover
in front of your uncle and it says that
your men there? Sorry. Can you tell me
what is the capital punishment or any
kind of punishment for a woman that
doesn't wear the hijab in Islamic state?
I thought so. Nor I thought so. Liam, I
still feel sorry for you. Man, if I
heard that, I'll be scared. It's what?
It's like watching a horror movie. Yeah.
That's made up. Absolute fiction. Where
is that? Yes. Absolutely. And and she's
thinking of, oh, it's deliberation, you
know. I mean, like, you know, when Noria
wears, you know, shows a cleavage or
wears miniskirts or high heels or does
makeup in two hours, gets a lip pierced,
etc. That's her own will. She has no
societal pressure, no pressure from the
opposite gender, not the beauty
industry, not Botox, not the Brazilian
buttlft. Of course not. In order chooses
to do that, the last time I read a book
called beauty sick, the author, a
non-Muslim author, was telling us that
women are so sexually objectified in the
west. Some of them starve theirel to
look the perfect body. They have a yoga
every four hours so they don't pass out.
And one woman was saying that basically
she was so she thought it was all about
beauty. It's called beauty sick that she
would go and sleep around with men for
validation. So Noria is right you know
she's you know she's not sexually
objectified. She chooses to show
cleavage show she chooses to wear a mini
skirt like you know in minus 3° when I'm
in Leicester Square giving da when we
see these girls walking out and they can
dress up however they like they're in
their land. Yes. minikrts. They choose
to in a freezing cold. They're like, "We
choose to show our legs." Not that they
are coerced by the stuff that they watch
and other people. No, no, no, no, no.
The only difference between a Muslim
woman and a non-Muslim woman when it
comes to their clothing is the
following. A Muslim woman is prescribed
something and a Muslim man, by the way,
from the get-go, from history, all
Christians, Jews, all dressed up like
that. Even Liam, look at the 1900s where
British women were dressed. Have you
seen that video where it says they're
showing her a woman with a cleavage and
they go, "Would you dress up?" She said,
"Oh, the British woman in the ' 50s or
the '7s '7s saying, "Oh, no. We won't
dress up like that." They had modesty.
You've lost your modesty. So, don't come
and talk to us about that. The only
difference is a Muslim woman obeys the
commandment of God Almighty. And a
non-Muslim woman, any woman or even
Muslim women who dress up in an
inappropriate way are following what?
The fashion industry, the beauty
industry, the Botox industry, the peer
pressure, the opposite gender. So, don't
come and tell us about freedom. You're
not having enough freedom. You are
controlled by the fashion industry and
so many other factors to tell you how to
dress and how to look. That's why you
guys are self-conscious. It
>> it was wild.
>> Chop Chop Square. That's a place I've
heard about in Saudi Arabia. What is
Chop Chop Square and what goes on there?
Chop Chop Square is a place in Riyad,
the capital of Saudi, where literally
after Friday prayers, um, according to
the Islamic Hadud punishments where, you
know, you get your right hand chopped
off if you stole something with your
right hand, your left hand chopped off
if you've done that. Um, they carry out
those amputations or worse, beheadings
in that area. And that's why it's known
as chop chop square. Saudi Arabia has a
designated executioner whose job it is
just to carry out these, you know, awful
punishments on the weekend. So, we had a
we had a chop chop square light, if you
will, where I lived in the city of Jada.
It was it was deemed to be a little bit
more liberal than Riad, thankfully. I
think life in Riyad would have been
absolutely stifling, but we would hear
of the same things. Um, so you can go to
a mosque on Friday because Friday is a,
you know, special prayer
>> for um, Muslims. Then afterwards, you're
welcome to go and see that.
>> Wow. Like their equivalent to the
theater, but you're watching people
getting executed publicly.
>> And here we go. We've come to the chop
chop square. Look how barbaric these
Muslims are. Chop chop square. You know,
if you just think about it, I just want
you guys to put it into perspective,
guys. Yeah. And I know a lot of people
in the far right or the right will agree
with me. The leftist, they won't. We me
and we're the far right. We've got
something here. We could Liam. Hey,
mate. We can hold hands here. Come on.
We can go. We can go uh have some lunch
together. You can have a uh you know,
some bacon sandwich. I'll have the halal
version. Interesting. So, let me get
this right. I'm a I'm a taxpaying
individual. So, I'm going to pay my tax.
I'm an innocent person. I I I abide by
the law. I'm like Tommy Robertson and
all the beating his wife wife up,
traveling with faith documents, illegal
immigrant in Canada, um flipping going
to prostitute, cheating on his wife, you
name so much stuff even though it's not
even though it's not a crime. Okay. So,
he goes sex exploitation. Okay. So, let
me get this right. So, I'm paying we're
the taxpayers. We're paying tax to
individuals who are robbing people in
broad daylight, robbing their phones,
raping innocent girls, pedophiles,
grooming gangs. Yes. Both white and
whatever you want to call ethnicity, who
cares? Yeah. The far right, they hate
they hate, look, they hate they don't
hate the crime. They hate who does the
crime. They hear it. They go, "It's a
grooming guy." Go, they're white. Oh,
no. It's a black guy, Asian guy. Is it a
Muslim? Which Islam's got nothing to do
with it. None of these individuals were
imams, religious leaders or nothing of
that. But they're like, "No, no, no. If
he's a Muslim, we hate him. If he's not,
that's so sick. I hate the act whoever
it's done to, and I would like a chop
chop square in Trfalga Square, and I
would have popcorn watching these people
getting executed one by one, my friend.
I would have nachos. I would have extra
jalapenos. Police." But they have a
problem that the taxpayers are paying
for their work. Check this out. You do
all of this crime, a little tap in the
hand. Naughty, naughty. Don't do that
again. You've taken somebody's life.
Naughty, naughty. Don't do that again.
You know, you rob someone's hard earned
life living. Naughty, naughty. Don't do
that. You can go to prison, get a couple
of months there. By the way, have hot
showers, nice hot meals, you want to
play PlayStation, you want to read some
books, have some fresh air. Ah, yes. Um,
you know, I've I've raped a
four-year-old girl, you scum,
four-year-old child, you dirt bag. Um,
I've done atrocities. I've killed
people. Um, I've robbed people. Um, but
chop chop square barbaric. No, no, not
chop chop square. How barbaric? But, um,
the taxpayer pays. So the criminals can
cause havoc and kill innocent people who
are paying their tax. Can you imagine me
looking after the man who kills it with
your own tax and Islam is barbaric? My
friend, you're dying for Sharia, bro.
You are dying for the Sharia. And this
is an Islamic in an Islamic country
where we have Jewish spirit. It's not
just you don't do like, you know,
hunters. No, there is a legal system
there. It doesn't work like there is a
legal system to go through. But no, no,
no. It's barbaric. Barbaric. Not even
that, Liam. And one of your comments I
saw was someone who had some brain. At
least he was like, "I'd love to have see
a chop chop square in Trafal Square."
He's downright, mate. I'll if I had the
means, I hope I would damn vote for all
of these criminals who are taking
advantage of pedophiles, bloody pedos,
and all these individuals who are
attacking and killing gang members,
killing innocent people who are afraid
to walk at night, leaving with your
family. When you walk at night, are you
safe? And in certain areas, no, you're
not. Why? Because Islam has come to
protect your right. And Islam deals with
it very severely. Because Islam deals
with the core, the solution is
pragmatic. not to Disneyland, you know.
Oh, we'll just let them go and then you
get upset about. I don't understand. You
don't want the Sharia. You complain. If
the Sharia comes, you've got an issue
with it. No Sharia got an issue with it.
What do you want, mate? There's
something I've heard about if a woman
is raped, there needs to be a certain
amount of witnesses. And if a woman has
been raped, she gets punished. Now, that
could be way off. I've heard it on a
number of occasions. Is there any truth
and substance to that? Yeah, you need to
um It's ridiculous. You need to
>> I I I love this. I love Nord's
confidence. She's like, "Oh man, oh my
gosh, man. I can't wait." Like as if and
and as if the funny thing is if she
spoke facts, she's so excited like, "Oh
my gosh, I can't wait to answer this.
Watch this." Now watch how I chop her
intellectually. Watch this.
>> Proof rape with four witnesses who have,
to say it like in a in a less graphic
way, to have seen the kind of fountain
pen in the ink position. Um, and you
need four men to have seen that. Why
they would have seen that, stood by and
done nothing is
>> I find it so interesting because she
actually thinks she's speaking fact
because she's like, "Oh, nobody's going
to take me to check. Oh, I didn't think
Ali Da will watch this video. Oh my
gosh, what am I going to do now?" So,
she's she's so flabbergasted. She's
like, "Oh my gosh, man." Like, you know,
I'm I'm so excited cuz I'm going to be
speaking so much facts. Yeah. Check this
out, guys. Watch watch watch how she's
going to get absolutely demolished
intellectually
>> on me. But that's kind of the uh
threshold in Islam. So like I grew up in
Saudi Arabia and Dubai. If a woman in
Dubai got raped or like I actually had
an art teacher in Saudi Arabia, a lovely
woman um and she was driven to the
middle of the desert at night by a taxi
driver. She got raped there and left out
there to die. She somehow made her way
back towards the city and got on the
flight the next day. Gave her
resignation to the school, never came
back. Um
>> okay, one sec. What the hell's that got
to do with anything? Let's go to okay
let's go to the prime source material
okay firstly okay let's go to hadith
this hadith look this is hadith this is
our tradition okay let's go and read
example of this okay here we go this is
uh okay it's authentic
al reported a woman went out to pray
during the time of the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him she was met by a man
who attacked her and raped her she
screamed and he ran away then another
man passed by and and she said this man
has molested me a group of immigrants
were passing by and then again they said
it's your fault for being raped. No, I'm
joking. That's not in the hadith. I just
made that by the way. Sorry. I know
you're excited. Oh yeah. No, sorry that
was no. Again said this man has molested
me. They caught the man whom she thought
was her attacker and brought him to her
and she said yes this is the one. They
brought him to the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him issuing orders
concerning him. But the one who actually
done the attacked her, stood up and
said, "Oh, mesh of Allah, I am the one
who attacked her." The prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said to her,
"You can go now." No, he didn't say,
"You're to blame. You're going to get
the capital punishment." Uh, and by the
way, there is nothing about four
witnesses here, Nora. Where did you get
that from? I don't think you know what
you're talking about, do you, darling?
Yes. Okay. The prophetam said, "Go now
for Allah has forgiven you." Meaning,
you falsely accuse somebody. Okay. But
God has forgiven you. Okay. Nobody.
She's free. Look, she's free to go.
Bye-bye. You can go. You're free. What
happened to the woman or this? You know,
you need four witnesses. No four
witnesses. No blaming the woman. What
happened to the man? Liam, this way
you're going to love the Sharia law, my
friend. You're going to love it, my
friend. Sharon law. Yeah. Okay. And the
prophet said kind words to the man who
had been falsely accused. He said, look,
I'm sorry, etc. Cuz right. The prophet
said to the man who had attacked her,
stone him. And the prophet said,
"Verily, he has repented in such a
manner that the people of Medina were to
repent in this way, it will be accepted
from them." Meaning that the man got the
capital punishment, chop chop square,
chop chop square of a rapist. What does
a rapist get here in this country? H
what did he get? What did he get? Huh?
Hot meals, hot shower, hot bed. Huh? So
he can come out and do the same thing
again. Why I'm going to pay taxpayers
money, my friend? Deal with it to the
core. No taxpayers money. I'm going to
pay tax money to somebody who's
committing these kind of atrocious acts.
Huh? What happened to her? Let me let me
let me let me read something else. Let's
read another one. Let's read another
one. Abdman alam reported
that you accused of darling listen
carefully. May Allah be pleased with him
was asked to a judge who had been
suffering from thirst. So she was
suffering from thirst. She had passed by
a shepherd and asked him for water. The
man refused to give her anything unless
she offered herself to him. So she had
intercourse with him. Omar consulted the
people whether she should be punished
for adultery. Ali Abal may Allah be
pleased with him said the this is
compulsion. I believe you should set her
free. Thus Omar set her free. Okay.
Imama said there is no legal punishment
upon a rape victim according to the
general opinion of scholars. It has been
narrated from Omar al Zada and
al Shafi and the people of reasoning. We
do not know of any disagreement. There
is no difference between rape by force
which is he had powered her raped by a
threat of death so on. So they said
she's not a victim rather the man who
committed adultery he will get flogged
or if he's married get a capital
punishment like these groomers who were
majority who were married both white and
these whatever call them Indians agents
whatever they for that matter. Okay.
Okay for that matter. Yes they get the
capital punishment. Sorry. Nia, what
happened to um four witnesses? What
happened to a woman? You know, what
happened? No,
>> an ideology that I just I'm never going
to fully accept. Well, I'm not going to
accept it period. Especially when you
know, you are telling me this. I'm not
talking to to to Jim down the pub who's
had a cut the bevies and he's he's
repeating what he's heard from someone
else in another pub. I'm talking to an
ex female Muslim that's lived in Saudi
Arabia. So, this is under Sharia law. So
by rights under Sharia law in Saudi
Arabia for example a woman can be raped
by a man and it can be witnessed by two
other men seeing the fountain pen going
into the ink. Very graphic and that
won't be enough.
>> No,
>> that won't be enough for a conviction.
You you'll still be deemed as the as the
perpetrator.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yes. I mean look Liam Liam here he's
like listen I'm not talking to some
idiot who's drunk in the pub who's heard
something about the Sharia law. He's
like I'm talking to an ex-Muslim. You
know this. Can you imagine? They're so
obsessed. They identify as ex-Muslim.
Imagine I had woman walking around
saying I am who are you? I am. They
don't even say the name. I am the
ex-wife of Ali Dawa. He said was I'm
starting to get a bit excited here.
Ex-wife Al. Well, I mean you identify. I
mean you must have I must have been a
good good husband. Ex-wife of Ali Dawa.
I'm an ex-wife Alidawa. Oh, I'm an
ex-wife Ali Dawa. I'm like bloody hell
man. So these these these ex-wives of
mine are quite bloody happy. You know
they're identifying, you know, not even
their name. So this is ex-Muslim. So
Liam's like, you know, yeah, she must
know what she's talking about. Uh, no.
Sorry, mate. Liam, I maybe this the
reason why you don't want to talk to me
because you know I'm going to
intellectually chop chop. Yes.
>> And interestingly, Liam, like I always
wondered why why four? Like what's this
obsession with four, but interestingly
it comes down to Aisha, Muhammad's child
bride, was accused of adultery at one
point. and Muhammad. And there were
three witnesses. And obviously Muhammad
did not want um that to be part of his
life story and to like have that on his
conscience that his child bride could
potentially be interested in somebody
her own age. And so he upped the level
to four. Uh which is why we're stuck
with this ludicrous thing we've got
today where women are, you know, raped
all the time and they're afraid to go to
the authorities
>> to think. Okay, fine. Interesting. No,
your credibility is gone. It's on minus
seven, man. It's like your credit score.
Like it's it's it's ex-Muslim credit
score is minus 700 right now. Okay, this
is funny man. Look, we got surah. Surah
was revealed about the accusation that
was done to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's uh wife. So let's go.
Okay, let's read it for oursel. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. Here we go. Okay. Okay. So
in verse uh four it says that you
thought you was going to get caught. Hey
Liam, come on mate. All right. So, so it
goes, "Those who accuse chase women of
adultery and fail to produce four
witnesses, give them 80 lashes each and
do not accept their testimony." Okay.
So, where did you get three from?
Please, can you bring evidence? I I want
to know. Where did you get evidence?
Three. Where's it three? Please tell me
where. Please tell me where. Where?
Where? Where? So, you just made that
stuff up. You just made that bull crap
up. It doesn't exist, man. We have
people over in the UK that protest
against people that object to Sharia law
that were born and bred in this country.
I mean, we've got a legal system over
here that that's always work very fine.
We're very civilized. We're very fair.
We're very balanced. We have a judge and
a jury and a legal system. Uh, and the
majority of the time, justice does
prevail. We don't need Sharia law over
here. And people are entitled to be
concerned about that. And I think people
should listen loud and clear to what you
just said. Even if you need to rewind
that little bit and listen to that back
under Sharia law, uh it's a completely
different universe of rules and it
doesn't go in the favor of the female.
Sorry mate. Sorry. Sorry. With all due
respect, Liam, sorry. Your judicial
system. Yeah. Your judicial system. We
just talked about the taxpayer paying
funding the criminals. They're getting a
pat on the hand for rape. Man, 95 or 97%
of women have been sexually harassed one
way or another. What are you talking
about my friend? What crime? What
punishment for people who are murdering
stabbing people on the streets and
getting couple of years and by the way
three four years that's two years cuz
they count as day and night. And on top
of if you're good behavior you come back
out to stab a few chop a few more
people. But if you if they get the chop
chop nuh-uh that's barbaric but go back
out as a a a repeat offender and chop
more a few people. 100% my friend. No
problem. Uh come on my friend Liam. You
do you want the Sharia? Please don't
don't I? I know you want the sharia. in
your eyes.
>> Again, I was trying to be clever about
it. And in Islam, I either belong to my
husband or my dad, right? I'm never
myself cuz I don't have any agency. So,
>> I don't know what the she's talking
about. This is absolute nonsense bull
crap. Because in Islam, when Islam came,
when the feminist was fighting for their
right in Islam, if I don't remember,
Nordia, you can check me on this,
please. Um, you don't need to take your
husband's surname because you don't
belong to him. But in the English law,
you have to when they get married, whose
surname does they take? The husbands. A
woman in Islam has a right to work 1400
years ago when the feminists were
ripping their hair out, you know, here
about 100 years ago. Rightly so, by the
way, yeah, they were throwing the self
in front of the carts of the the the
king. Okay. Um, in Islam, you are to
allowed to get divorced. In Christianity
and Judaism, uh, no, you are not, my
friend. And not only that, if I don't
remember falsely, Tommy Roberts, you're
a Christian now, aren't you, my friend?
You know, in the Bible, it says if you
rape a woman um, and then you have to
marry, you pay 50 shekels to the
husband, I mean to the father. Okay. So,
uh, which one are you talking about?
When Islam in the Quran says that they
used to bury girls alive, innocent baby
girls alive because they were girls.
Allah forbade that and condemn that and
came to abolish that. So I can go on and
on. The rights that they have a Muslim
woman, my wife, I have to pay for
everything.
Everything. Yes, I'm telling you. Okay.
Islam takes care of everything. So what
are you talking about? Islam gives a
right. doesn't sexually objectify women,
you know, dress naked, you know, wear a
bikini, you know, wear a miniscuit so
you can be sexually objectified and
taken advantage of. Islam says a woman
is a human being. She has a soul. Okay?
When she covers up, it's so men doesn't
talk to somewhere else. It talks to her
as a human being. She has a brain. She
has more than offer. Islam acknowledges
that a woman is created in a way that
there is there's a desire from the
opposite gender. It's pragmatic. It's
real. So it says there are idiots out
there. So that's the reason why Islam
tells the men to lower his gaze and
guard his chastity and dress up
modestly. And they say the same to the
woman to do their job. Why? Because if
you look at it, men are visual
creatures. That's the reason why men are
the ones who watch majority pornography,
buy adult uh uh movies, by adult
magazines, etc. Okay? That's the reason
why God Almighty acknowledges that a
woman is like a diamond. And what you do
with your diamond? You say, "Hey guys,
look, look what I've got. So you get
robbed." No. So that's the reason why
Islam acknowledges how precious a woman
is and tells her to cover because people
can listen to her brain, not judge her
by her appearance, okay? Hey, like the
western world does. Putting a bloody
woman in a bikini in in a chocolate bar.
Get out of here, mate.
>> When I got back here and I kind of dealt
with the PTSD and I had some time to
recuperate and just kind of think about
what happened to me. I thought, hold on
a second. They justified this using
Sharia. I studied, dabbled in Islamic
law a little bit. I call myself a
Muslim. Let me see if God cuz I knew
Sharia is is divine law. It's Islamic
law comes straight out of the Quran.
It's not even like man-made. It's it's
actually God's words turned into the law
that is infallible and it's timeless. So
I thought, how can that law
want that for me or do that to me? And
obviously I'm back in the UK, so there's
no restrictions on the internet like
there are in the UAE with um you can't
even search anything about Islam that
could be contrarian. So for the first
time in my life, I actually as a grown
woman was like, "Let me see what Sharia
law says about women." And not just
that, let me see what the Quran says
about women because they've got Sharia
from the Quran. So I went straight and I
read, I was like, "Screw the Arabic. Let
me read it in English, word for word."
And what I read, I was absolutely
disgusted. Like Quran 4:24, that whole
verse, the verse of women. Surah Nissa
says like men are in charge of women
because they are a degree above them.
Okay. So, she goes to Saudi Arabia to
study Islam. She knows about Quran. She
memorizes it. For some odd reason, when
she's in Saudi Arabia, she doesn't know
nothing about the Quran. The Quran that
she's memorizing, she doesn't know. And
apparently, there's no internet there.
Okay, no problem. She comes back to UK
and goes, "Yo, hold on a second, man.
Let me go on Google. We've got Google
internet. Let me check what it says
about this woman. Oh my gosh." Okay.
What does it say about woman? Can you
please tell me? I will listen. Listen. I
will intellectually dismantle you. I
dare you to show me, Subhan Allah, where
the greatest woman. Show me where. Show
me where. Show me where it says that.
And you're talking about there. Of
course, a woman, a man has more
responsibility. Who has built the world
around you? Men. Men have done it to
serve women. So, it's a responsibility.
It's not a perk. When I'm walking with
my wife Liam, you too. Yes. You are the
protector and the provider, my friend.
There is no 50/50 in Islam. You are the
best to Liam. If your wife's watching
this, you're going to say, "Listen,
Liam, you better you better accept
Islam." Yeah. Okay. You are the
protector and the provider. If someone
tries to say something to your wife, you
have to protect her. So, which means
what? It is irresponsible. you're
risking, you're more at risk. Okay? When
a burglar comes in to your house, is
your wife going to go and fight? No,
you're going to go and fight. So, it's
what? That's why Islam gives that one
above responsibility to the man because
he's the protector and provider. So
again, Nuria, your credit score is
dropping. Your ex-Muslim credit score is
plummeting. Was you in danger? Are you
in danger? Will you be in danger?
>> Will I? I'm not sure. I'm hoping to stay
safe. I have thus far, but um
>> touch would you do stay safe, by the
way. I'm not tempting fate. I'm just
curious.
>> No, for sure. And I know I'm I'm very
aware um and acutely aware of, you know,
the changing threat always. Like, you
know, there's some parts of London I
would never touch. There's some parts of
the UK I would never, you know, go to
just for my own safety. But it takes
one, it takes one, you know, nutter to
kind of be a little bit inspired that
day to do something to you.
>> I mean, with all due respect, man, this
this whole like, you know, the ex-Muslim
hype has died down. That was 10 years
ago. Oh, we're ex-Muslim. We're ex
Muslim. Please, withhold your respect,
man. The only threat that you have is
this intellectual chopping that just
happened. Now that you have no other
threat, please for God's sake, get this.
Like, oh, we're in danger. They Nobody
withhold your respect. You have been
replaced by thousands of Western women
have come to Islam. Allah says in the
Quran, we will replace you. You have
been replaced so fast. No, without due
respect, with your IQ level, with all
due respect, all this stuff that you
made up, which are absolute lies,
without actually it's, you know, you've
left, there's no damage done here to
Islam. Islam doesn't need you. We're in
our DA table. We've got thousands of
people around the world coming to Islam.
So, please save it, mate. Or they'll go
some place to London. Get the hell out
of here.
>> Muslim friends around will say like
there's no compulsion in religion or you
know, if you kill one person, it's akin
to killing all of humankind. And they
take all these nice bits out of the
Quran. But what they don't understand is
that there's a doctrine of abrogation in
Islam. Which means that all those fluffy
nice verses have been overridden by the
violent verses because those were the
verses that were revealed when Muhammad
was in Mecca when he barely had anyone
on his side and it was in his interest
to be nice and peaceloving and rainbow
and unicorns. when he did the migration
to Medina, the Hijra, it goes, "Kill all
the disbelievers, you know, make them
pay the Jizian, be humbled, uh they're
the worst of creatures." It all changes.
>> Okay. So, that's absolute bull crap
because in the Quran in Surah Bakar, if
I'm not mistaken, uh it's verse 25. I
can't remember. Yes. Okay. It says,
"There is no compulsion in religion.
Truth is clear from falsehood. Please
bring evidence that's been abregated.
Please bring evidence that has been
abregated in Sah 60:8
and it says, "Allah does not forbid you
from being just and kind to those who
did not fight you based on your faith
and kick you out of your houses. Tell me
evidence that that's been abregated
using terminologies and Liam there
doesn't know what you're talking about.
He's like a Muslim. You must be seeking
the truth. You're an absolute liar.
You've been caught out. This is probably
the eighth or ninth lie. You're making
up stories as it goes, bro. Talking
about Harry Potter." Yeah, my friend.
You're making lies up. So tell me one of
those verses and you're talking about uh
uh that the prophet when he was weak
etc. Okay, let's go to the Quran. Let's
go to Quran. Haj verse 39 permission to
fight has been is hereby granted to
those who've been fought for they have
been wronged and Allah is truly most
capable. So it says permission to fight
back has been given to those who've been
fought unjustly. And you know from the s
which I don't think you know you're a
liar probably you're you're ignorant or
a liar. We know the prophetam was
persecuted, tried to be assassinated,
they were starved, they were boycotted
for 23 years until this verse was
revealed to then defend yourself. Would
you say to someone for 23 years who've
been persecuted that if they defend the
wrong like Liam, you talk about these
immigrants in these hotels and this kind
of stuff and agreement gangs or
whatever, etc., you know, you've had
enough, you've had enough. Um, would you
be blamed? Would you be blamed if if
your cause is right, which we believe
your cause is not right. Yeah. If your
cause was genuine that you were against
all kind of culprits who do these
issues, grooming gangs, pedophiles,
etc., we were behind you fully. But your
cause is corrupt. You care more about
the culprit than the victim. So much so
certain grooming gang victims who have
said that their their perpetrators were
white men were threatened. Yeah. The
kids were threatened to throw been
thrown into the temps or something like
that because she said, "Well, hold on a
second. It's not just Asians or
whatever." It was actually the white
people. No, no, no, no. Don't say that.
You sicko. You bloody sickos. Yes. Okay.
So, don't come with that nonsense,
please. Let's carry on. We're nearly
done.
>> I've seen that. And what people This is
the moment where the provocative leftist
will jump in the in the comments on
YouTube and say, "Well, there's there's
domestic violence within Christianity,
within Britain, within the white
community, whatever. There it will be
the the what about this?" Mhm.
>> So just to please them,
we have more than enough domestic
violence within our Christian atheist,
white British community than we would
like, than we care for. And just to put
it on record, if I was aware that there
was a man in my community beating on his
wife or girlfriend because she was
joining in with him singing and I got
wind of it, I would draw him.
>> Is it? You draw him. Go draw. Go draw
Tommy Robinson. Go draw Tommy Robinson,
bro. Yeah, he is known. He was caught by
undercover officer while he was abusing
his wife. Go draw a Yemen who threw a
flipping chopping board at his wife. Go
draw Paul Golding who was locking up
Jada. Go draw him, man. Why did you go
draw him? Why go draw him, Liam? Huh?
Why do you go draw them? Oh, are they
your buddies? Yeah. I admire that you
reported your father to the police
because of his pedophilia actions or
whatever he was doing for that matter.
We should discuss and I and I salute you
for that as a man to man. You got you're
a man of principle. Who do you love
more? Your father or Tommy Robinson?
Huh? You said you still have love and I
understand. I'm not blaming you for
that. Is your father. Yes. So why don't
you go and draw Tommy Robinson? Yeah.
Who always punches people who can't
punch back. Little flipping intellectual
coward, bro. Yes. People that
can't come back. Uh can't punch him
back. Yeah. So why don't you go draw
them? Yes. They all known. They all
known. Yes. Why Peter? Stella. What's
the What's the drink Stella known for,
mate? Liam, what's it known for? E wife
Peter's drink. wife beat his drink. When
football hooligans, their team loses,
what do they do? They beat their wives
up, mate. Yeah. Okay. So, the same
applies. So, one second. Hold on a
second. So, if this is a problem
universally that there are bad and good
people who do good and bad stuff, what's
your point about Islam
debunked? If your claim is okay to the
left is okay, they make a point. If this
white people do it, brown people do it,
green people do it, aliens do it,
everyone do it, then what's your point?
Why are you making it seem like it's
only Islam? Yeah. Why? Look, let's give
an example. Okay. Islam says beat your
wife up. Yeah, whatever. Nonsense. Yeah.
Okay. What's your excuse for beating
your wife up, bro? What's your excuse?
Okay, the religion tells us apparently,
"Yeah, bull crabby. I got a big stick at
home. I beat my wife up with." Okay, so
what's your excuse, man? Why are you
beating your wife? And for those that
are don't aren't familiar with that
phrase, I would physically attack him if
that was done in front of me and it
would stop there and then. That's
somebody in my own community because
people love to do that.
>> Yep.
>> You're having a sensible conversation.
What about It's like, yeah, we're not
talking about that. The fact that we're
talking about one group of people
doesn't mean that we're pretending it
doesn't happen within other groups of
people. So, it's important to do that
now because we know that there's so many
mentally unhinged leftists out there
that just want to argue for the sake of
arg and then like yeah, yeah, yeah. He
just disproved all your points, all the
stuff that you made up. There are good
people and bad people. You lied about
Islam. And the last final point, guys,
this has been emotional. I'm going to
I've I've loved filming this last point.
What's life been like since leaving
Islam
>> on a personal level? Amazing. Absolutely
amaz I mean it's the sweet taste of
freedom, you know, like mental
emancipation, physical emancipation.
You're not this walking body of shame.
You're not temptation in that way. Um
you're not you're not going to get
roasted in hell for, you know,
befriending a gay person. Um so yeah, on
a personal level, it's been more
liberating than ever. I I'm I can live
my life. I'm I'm in the driving seat. I
don't not restricted by any of those
weird archaic dictates that Sharia
ordains for you. Not even like the
societal pressure of the community cuz
I've said sorry I'm out of here. I'm not
part of what you think how you think.
You can't police me anymore.
>> You can't believe sorry. Where does it
say that befriending gays
hellfire? That's the problem. The 10th
lie you made. Where does it say
befriending gay? I've speak to so many
gay people. Okay. And I've had someone
who I deem to like just a friend or
someone I see regular. How the hell do I
end up in hell? Why you getting this non
I don't know what kind of Islam you
followed, but damn right it's not the
Islam that we follow. And now she's like
now she's uh uh she's liberated now. She
goes on dates, you know, she goes on
dates and I'm not going to lie, you
know, looking at old videos, etc. She's
even put on weight. I think she's doing
really well ex-Muslim. Thank God. Carry
on. Bye-bye. All the best in the future.
Yes. As you can see, she's more free
now. You know, she can go sleep around.
She can do whatever. She's her own
woman. You know, there'll be men who are
coming and giving her false promises
having sex with her cuz it's casual sex.
You know, in the Western world, it's
totally fine. You know, and they say,
you know, I've changed my mind. Sorry,
I'm not really feeling you. Bye-bye.
They go. She's liberated. She can wear
what she wants. Liberation. Yes. Not
that she's affected by Netflix or
Instagram or social media or peer
pressure or the beauty industry or the
opposite gender or her friends around
her. Uh uh uh. Or the men. No, no, no,
no, no. Nia chooses. She's free. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. You keep your freedom to
yourself. Alhamdulillah. I found my true
freedom when I enslave myself to Allah
subhana wa tala and I follow that. Guys,
it's been emotional. Liam, I hope you
enjoyed that. I'm sure you cracked a few
laugh here and there, mate. Uh it's been
interesting and I look forward to
meeting you one day. Uh maybe on on
maybe on Saturday, you know, if you come
and see me, I would I would love it. I
would love to meet you and your other
farright friends. Uh hopefully for a
nice peaceful discussion. It'll be nice
to see you guys. Till next time, brother
and sisters from Ali Dawa. Asalamu
alaykum.
What better?